we recently got to preview team ninjas
neo2 and it's very much a continuation
of the methodical soul style samurai
combat from the original set several
decades before the first game you play
as a nameless samurai who defies death
by merging with a yokai spirit as a
being of both the human and demon worlds
your custom character is able to use
both conventional human weapons like
katanas Spears in the new transformer
will switch glaive along with a suite of
demonic attacks that channel the spirits
of slain yokai while neo2 sticks close
to the foundation set by its predecessor
a lot of attention has been given to
refining the core combat the online
co-op gameplay and how you develop and
evolve your character as they explore
Sengoku era Japan from our recent
hands-on gameplay where we explored a
castle overrun by demons and rogue ninja
it was clear that the high-stress
gameplay remains intact which included
all those pesky sudden deaths that are
entirely your fault because you weren't
paying attention to your surroundings
still I'd say that the section of neo to
be played is fair in how it throws
challenges your way due to the number of
tools and skills you've got at your
disposal continuing on from the original
games Diablo style RPG loot system and
character building set up the sequel
takes things further with an overhauled
skill and ability system that allows you
to develop your hero in ways that best
reflect your style want to stick with
your learnings of proper samurai
patience and resolve you can do that or
perhaps you want to lean more into the
teachings of the ninja and own mule
allowing you to buff your weapons with
elemental damage you can certainly
follow those paths as well but what
really makes neo to so different from
the original is the addition of yokai
powers after slaying powerful demons
throughout the world you'll be able to
claim their souls to elevate your
strength in battle there's something
especially satisfying about slaying a
powerful demon and then claiming their
soul for yourself by using these
abilities in combat you're able to
exploit and opponent's weakness opening
them up for several quick and powerful
strikes but when things get particularly
hairy you're also able to enter a full
on yokai state which significantly
amplifies your strength and agility one
demon form you take on for example who
wields a set of daggers grants you a
useful - move that can get you out of
trouble in a pinch following a round of
alpha and beta tests developer team
ninja has refined to the core gameplay
even more these changes include tweaking
boss attacks and amplifying the
effectiveness of weapons which will
hopefully make the final game a bit more
even while the difficulty has always
been a point of contention for soul
style games neo - doesn't totally send
you up the river without a paddle
there are far more options for you to
take advantage of here which helps
overcoming the many harrowing encounters
ultimately feel more satisfying than the
original set for release on march 13th
neo - sticks close to what made the
original game great while also fleshing
out its own identity there's so much
going on in neo - but well let this
gameplay speak for itself in the
following footage we show off more
exploration of the castle the various
combat skills your character has and
what sort of strange events you can find
when going on
the beaten path
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]